التداول في سماء المملكة المتحدة الممطرة
للاعب الجولف الإنجليزي المحترف في صن شاين تومي فليتوود وزوجته
كلير في تنقلاتهم اليومية
في عام 2022، افتتح أول
أكاديمية فليتوود للجولف على الإطلاق في الشرق
الأوسط، وقد أتيحت
لنا الفرصة لجلب
الأكاديمية إلى هنا، وهي  كل ما في الأمر هو أن كل أنواع
المحاذاة التي اعتقدنا أنها نعم،
دعنا نجربها، دعنا ننتقل
إلى دبي، وقد تم سدادها حتى الآن،
نعم ولكن هذه علامة جيدة على أن الرجل البالغ
من العمر 32 عامًا وعائلته
يعيشون في  طيران الإمارات منذ العام الماضي،
أحبها الأطفال تمامًا، وهم
سعداء للغاية وقد استقرنا جيدًا، وكان
الجميع ودودين للغاية وجعلونا
نشعر وكأننا في منزلنا، لذلك كان هذا
جزءًا رائعًا حقًا من الأمر، بينما جعل
دبي منزلًا هو أمر رائع  كان
جلب لعبة الجولف إلى المنطقة أولوية قصوى
وكان أيضًا محركًا رئيسيًا. أعتقد أن الجولف
رياضة تنمو باستمرار هنا. أعتقد أن
فرصة النمو كبيرة ولكن
كما تعلمون، فإن اهتمامي الأكبر
بالجولف هو استخدامه للدفع.  يجب على الأشخاص
مطاردة أحلامهم
ومنحهم المهارات اللازمة للقيام بذلك، نعم
الحركة الجيدة ومهارات الوعي الجسدي الجيدة
التي تتعلمها لاعبة الجولف الصغيرة مايا بالانزا جودين البالغة من العمر 12 عامًا
في
أكاديمية فليتوود، لذا إذا كنت ترغب في
الحصول على بضع طلقات
فهو في  الوقت الذي كنا فيه في أكاديمية فليتوود، إحدى
قيمها الرئيسية هي أننا نريد أن
نجعل لاعبينا يتمتعون
بحركة جيدة خاصة
بالأفراد، لذلك على سبيل المثال عندما
ننظر إلى مايا هناك تبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا
وتتطور لتصبح كذلك.
رياضي مبتدئ رائع لأنني أعلم أنني
أخسر ما يقرب من 10 إلى 20 ياردة من المسافة،
نعم يمكننا العمل مع
أعضاء النادي أو لاعبي الغولف الترفيهيين أو
محترفي الرحلات أو لاعبي الغولف المبتدئين ولكن
ما نحاول القيام به بشكل أساسي هو
أننا  إن استخدام هذه التكنولوجيا لإعطاء
لاعبي الغولف فكرة أفضل عما
يفعلونه وربما ما يحتاجون إلى القيام به بشكل
أفضل قليلاً ومن ثم كيف يمكننا أن
ننظر إلى تحسين الجودة، إن
تحسين الجودة وحب
اللعبة ليس مجرد هدف بالنسبة لنا.
فليتوود ولكن حلم
أريد أن ألهم الناس وأريد
تحفيز الناس وأريد في الواقع
مساعدة الأشخاص ذوي المهارات للقيام بكل ما
يريدون، والشغف
الذي يجلبونه يحصل على
المحترفين بنفسي وكل من
يأتي إلى هناك سيلعب دورًا
دورًا كبيرًا في الجو، ومن ثم
الراحة التي يشعر بها الناس عندما
يأتون إلى هنا
ويأتون إلى هنا يفعلون ذلك من أجل حب
الجولف. يقول فليتوود إنه منذ
افتتاح الأكاديمية، زارها أكثر من 500 لاعب جولف
حتى الآن، حيث
يستمتع فليتوودز بالسماء المشمسة.  دبي
[موسيقى]